قال مندوب فلسطين لدى الامم المتحده رياض
منصور انه من غير المعقول ان يكون مجلس
الامن يدين العدوان الاسرائيلي على غزه
ويحذر من توسع الصراع وفي الان نفسه يمنع
من اصدار قرار يدعو لوقف اطلاق النار في
غزه لا يمكن لاحد ان يفهم ان مجلس الامن
يدين العدوان على المدنيين ويدعو لوقفه
وللدخول غير المشروط لمساعدات الانسانيه
ويرفض الترحيل القسري لسكان قطاع غزه
ويبدي قلقه من توسع الصراع وفي الوقت نفسه
يمنع من اصدار قرار يدعو الى وقف اطلاق
النار انه انفصام يجب ان يتوقف فورا
153 دوله صوتت لوقف اطلاق النار في
الجمعيه العامه والامين العام للامم
المتحده والمنظمات الانسانيه والملايين
يتظاهرون في شوارع العالم بما في ذلك
الولايات المتحده من اجل وقف اطلاق النار
الموقف الاخلاقي والشرعي والمسؤول الوحيد
هو دعم وقف اطلاق
النار